DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there,
I'm Daniel Sieberg in
the Google TV booth.
And I am en-Thuuz-iastically
talking
with Brandon and Jordan.
Brandon, tell us who you are and
what Thuuz is all about.
BRANDON FIELDS: All right.
I'm a software engineer
with Thuuz.
And Thuuz is a sports
application.
And it's all about finding an
exciting game to watch because
in today's TV land there's just
tons of games to watch at
any particular time.
So we try to make it easy for
a user to find the most
exciting games.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
So Jordan, you're going to help
us out by kind of driving
the action here.
JORDAN TOOR: I can do that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So give us sort
of a run through Brandon
of what we're seeing as Jordan's
controlling things.
JORDAN TOOR: Sure.
So Thuuz is enabling discovery
of exciting games.
This is our home screen
for the Google TV app.
It's currently showing that my
personalized sports-- there's
two live games going
on right now.
So we're going to go ahead
and jump into here.
This is personalized to my
favorite sports and my
favorite teams.
You can see here in the middle
we have two live games going
on right now, the Dodgers
and the Giants.
You can see earlier today, games
off to the left with
more exciting games
ranked to the top.
DANIEL SIEBERG: What do those
numbers reference to?
BRANDON FIELDS: Those are
excitement ratings that we
come up with based on an
algorithm that computes
several factors based on pace
of the game, novelty of the
plays, rivalry of the
teams, big come
backs, things like that.
Hundreds of factors go
into making a number
between 0 and 100.
100 being the best game ever.
So I mean if you could imagine
the Giants perfect game a week
or two ago, that was 100
on our Thuuz scale.
So here we have the
Giants game.
Let's just go ahead and
go into here and
see what we've got.
This is 3-0 Dodgers.
This is our excitement graph
throughout the different
innings of the game.
We try to propagate where you
can actually watch the game.
So we're working closely
with Dish Network.
So we can actually tune into
this game right now, or we can
actually choose to record
this game to our DVR.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So for rights
purposes, we don't want to get
in trouble.
So we're not showing any of that
stuff, but of course you
could have the game on while
you're doing all this stuff
and see it at the same time.
BRANDON FIELDS: Correct.
Correct.
And we try to make it really
easy, just one click, switch
to the channel.
We also give you summary and
stats and online resources
where you can actually catch
highlights, condensed video,
things like that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now I see the
Friends tab up at the top.
What's that all about?
BRANDON FIELDS: So we recently
added some social features.
So instead of commenting on a
game or sharing a game, we
call it Thuuzing a game.
So Google's a verb.
We're trying to make
Thuuz a verb.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So you get a
certain number of Thuuzes.
BRANDON FIELDS: Yeah, so here
we got a couple people that
have Thuuzed this particular
game already today.
And that's basically what
Friends is all about, going
out and finding your friends so
you could follow them, and
you guys can have conversations
about exciting games.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
JORDAN TOOR: Hop over
to DVR here?
BRANDON FIELDS: Yeah, let's
actually hop over to the DVR.
So one exciting feature we
worked on really hard
specifically for Google I/O is
integrating with the Dish box.
So what we're doing here is
we're making automated rules
based on your personal
preferences, maybe it's your
favorite team, maybe it's
a favorite sports
league that you like.
But we'll automatically go out
and record the game to your
DVR for you, the app will.
All you have to do
is set up a rule.
So you can see here, we're
really into Euro
soccer right now.
So we have a rule set up to
record all the European games.
We're really Giants fans, so
we've set a high priority that
we're going to go ahead
and record every
single Giants game.
Or you can use our algorithm to
say, hey, when some other
game I might not know about gets
really exciting, go ahead
and record it to
my DVR for me.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It's
very cool.
So it's almost thinking
for you in a sense.
It's taking all the hassle out
of figuring out which games
are on, which ones might
I like, all that stuff.
It's happening at
the same time.
BRANDON FIELDS: Yeah.
So it's all about discovering
games that maybe you might not
have known about.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Just real quick,
any sort of advice for
developers out there looking
at Google TV as a platform,
things you've learned, lessons
you want to pass along?
BRANDON FIELDS: For sure.
I mean there's definitely the
mindset of a 10-foot UI.
It's a bigger screen.
Your users are going to be
sitting further away from it.
So you gotta leverage the
layouts to handle that.
There's integration with the
tuners with whatever your
cable box is, a TiVo,
a Dish, a DIRECTV.
Being able to change the channel
right then and there
is a pretty cool.
Integrating with DVR
to automatically
record things is--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Well this
is awesome stuff.
I'm a big hockey fan so I'm
excited for when, of course,
NHL gets back in action.
But guys, thank you so much.
Brandon and Jordan we
appreciate this
little tour of Thuuz.
BRANDON FIELDS: Thank
you so much.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All
right thanks guys.
We're going to move on here.
You know, I am a
huge poker fan.
And I hear that there's an
awesome Zynga poker game.
And here we are with Zynga
to talk about it.
What a coincidence.
And I'm joined by
Jen and Andrew.
So Jen, tell me what Zynga
Poker is all about.
And I notice you've got multiple
devices here as well.
JEN HERMAN: Yep.
So Zynga Poker is Zynga's
first game.
It was created back in 2007.
It was first created
on the PC.
And we've since launched
the game on mobile
across multiple platforms.
So we started on Android mobile
phones and then moved
to tablets.
And most recently we've
moved to Google TV.
So it's pretty exciting for us
to support all of these great
Android devices.
And with Google TV one of the
things that we can do is we
can play in a five-
or nine-person
tournament at a table.
And Andrew is going to give you
a demo of how that works.
So let's check that out.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
Andrew go for it card shark.
ANDREW LEONIDAS: Well, I'm on
the main game table right now,
and in a moment you're going to
see how we've been able to
optimize our layout for the
various Android devices and
platforms that are currently
on offer.
Right now we're looking at the
Google TV version, which we've
developed for the TV DPI
density, which coincidentally
is exceptionally close
to the new
seven-inch Nexus 7 densities.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It looks
gorgeous, yeah.
ANDREW LEONIDAS: So
it's a direct port
of our Nexus 7 version.
I can log in with my Zynga
Poker account.
All my chips are there
across platforms.
All my friends are there.
I'm losing pretty
badly right now.
Most of my stack's
already gone.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It's hard to
talk and play at the same time
and hold a microphone.
ANDREW LEONIDAS: Yeah, I made a
bit of a rookie error whilst
I was navigating
the microphone.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
all right.
So you folded with those
pair of aces.
That's all right.
So Jen, you've got a Nexus
7 in your hand right?
JEN HERMAN: Yeah.
So just to talk about
this a little bit.
One of the things that as we
build our games for the
Android platform we use a
multi APK so that we can
support all of these different
formats with a single SKU.
And, as you know, we could
distribute our same game for
the tablet and for the phone
and for Google TV within
Google Play.
So it's great as a publisher
to be able to
do that in one place.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Can you show us
the experience on here too?
JEN HERMAN: Yeah.
So what we're going to do--
I've got the tablet here.
And one of the things that we've
done-- what's really
important for Zynga as a company
is that playing Zynga
games is a social experience.
So you want to be able to play
with your friends and your
family no matter
where they are.
But what's really cool on the
Android phone and tablet now,
we've been able to integrate
beam technology so that you
can play with whoever's
nearby.
So we're going to show you
how to do that right now.
Andrew is going to bust
out his Galaxy
phone, and we are gonna--
ANDREW LEONIDAS: All right,
let's take a look.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So can you hold
these up to the camera
just a bit so we can see what
the experience is like?
ANDREW LEONIDAS: So if I'm
joined to a table, or if I'm
simply watching a game, and I
have a friend nearby who also
has a beam-enabled
device, I can--
if all goes correctly--
place the rear of my device
against hers--
JEN HERMAN: And then
I touched a beam.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Just touched
a beam there
on the screen, yeah.
JEN HERMAN: And my game's
starting up.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So now you're
joining the same game that
Andrew's in, right?
JEN HERMAN: Yep.
ANDREW LEONIDAS: And
now we're joined.
JEN HERMAN: And I can spectate
or I can play.
So I was just chose to
spectate while I
watch Andrew over here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Who's a
better player here?
I have to--
ANDREW LEONIDAS: I think
Jen has a bigger stack
than me right now.
But I'm going to
take this one.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right, well
anything else you guys
wanted to mention while
you're in [INAUDIBLE]?
JEN HERMAN: We wanted to show
you a little bit on this new
Nexus 7 tablet.
So some of the things that we've
done that we think are
great on the device are we've
really tried to implement
fragments and really
take advantage
of the tablet device.
It's such a beautiful screen,
and we love it.
So a couple other things--
so where we would normally have
multiple screens that you
would go to, we've actually
implemented fragments here so
that you can see in a drop down
some of the other screens
that you would have to jump
around and navigate.
So we think that really being
able to take advantage of the
high-density screen and the
mobility of this form factor
is really going to
be great for game
players and poker players.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very cool.
Well, I can't wait
to check it out.
I've got to get my hands
on one of these
Nexus 7's at some point.
JEN HERMAN: Yeah, we want to
see you at a table soon.
Get some chips from you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And I'll take
some chips from Andrew.
All right, Jen and Andrew
from Zynga.
Thank you guys, we
appreciate it.
All right, I'm going to head
off to the next one.
We'll see you guys later.
JEN HERMAN: Bye bye.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
On our third stop of this
trifecta at Google TV, we're
joined by Ken from iHeart Radio
Now iHeart Radio, as a
lot of folks will know, has
been around for a while.
But as an app for Google TV it's
only been about a month.
How--
or is it-- different than what
people are used to and walk me
through some of the different
features.
KEN COLTON: All right.
So first of all it's really
exciting to get to work in a
brand new platform
like Google TV.
And we have so much screen real
estate to take advantage
of to really display
our content in new
and interesting ways.
So you still have access to
all of our great radio
stations in custom radio.
And we're just going to display
it in a really visual
and interesting way.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right, I
see more pictures here.
Of course, just as you say, you
have more real estate to
display all that stuff.
Now walk me through some of the
buttons that we can see on
the left there and how people
can interact with
it using the remote.
KEN COLTON: All right.
We divided everything into
Find, Create, and Search.
And Find lets you go and find
live stations near you or live
stations by genre.
Create lets you create your own
custom radio stations by
just typing in an artist or a
song, and it will choose other
songs that are like that song
and continue to play that.
Search, you can search
for anything.
It will find all the content
in our library for you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And how many
lives stations are out there
these days?
KEN COLTON: So we have over
1,000 live stations.
And we have custom stations
that can be made from over
400,000 artists or over
10 million songs.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
Cool.
Well, give us a demonstration of
what it's like to listen to
a song here on Google TV.
KEN COLTON: All right.
So I can just go over
to my Now Playing
section and hit Play.
And I'll play that guy.
And it'll just start
playing songs.
And you have this gorgeous
album art display.
And it will show you what radio
station you're listening
to and just great to
leave up on the TV.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right, so
we're only going to play about
10 or 15 seconds, just
for rights purposes.
But of course, if you were at
home on the comfort of your
couch you could listen to
whatever you want to or during
a party or however you
want to display it.
Tell me a little bit about that
development process for
Google TV, what it was like.
You're on the development
team yourself?
KEN COLTON: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And I know it
happened in a fairly short
amount of time.
KEN COLTON: Yes.
So we decided to build this as
an HTML5 web application, and
it wound up in the Google TV
spotlight that showcases web
applications that are optimized
for Google TV.
And by choosing HTML5 as our
technology, we were able to
build this application with a
team of only three people is
just one month and really come
up with the best user
experience by iterating
quickly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Any advice for
other development teams out
there looking at Google TV,
whether they have an existing
app already or they're looking
to maximize it for this
experience?
I know earlier we talked about
real estate and just thinking
about that versus maybe
a smaller screen.
KEN COLTON: Yeah, you definitely
want to customize
your app for the
TV experience.
And if you really focus on that
and don't be afraid to
push the envelope, you
can come up with a
really awesome app.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Were you
guys testing it out
on a TV this size?
I mean, is this the ideal place
for you to test out
something like this?
KEN COLTON: Well, we started
designing for a TV this size.
But one of the challenges of
building interface is making
sure that it works
for smaller TVs.
So we designed an interface
that's easy to use at a large
size like this and
looks great.
But it's also just as functional
on a smaller size.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And in terms
of sharing your choices or
something, that sort of social
element to it, how is that
part of this Google TV app?
KEN COLTON: The social
is deeply
integrated into iHeart Radio.
We have the ability to share
what you're listening to to
Facebook and invite other people
to try custom stations
that you created.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very cool.
Can you tell me what's coming
down the pike with this,
anything you're looking at as
a road map to the future?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Well, we're
looking to just really build
out this Now Playing screen by
showing information about
artists from Twitter or any
other real-time information
that we have just to make this
Now Playing experience as
awesome as possible.
As well as just rolling out new
stations and new features
that are available on
our other platforms.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very cool.
So take me back to that main
screen if you can.
And that Me, what's
that down there?
Is that a profile of your
own preferences?
KEN COLTON: So this shows you
all of the stations that
you've created and all of the
songs that you've liked.
So I can go in and see the
stations that I've created and
very quickly jump back into
those stations and start
playing them.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So it's
like your own personal
history sort of thing.
KEN COLTON: Yeah.
And this persists across
all of our platforms.
So you can start listening to
station on your Android device
and then pick it up here
and just go right back.
It'll be right at the top, and
you can start playing again.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Oh, that's
a great point.
So if you're an iHeart Radio
user and you start listening
to something on the TV or
you've created your
preferences, you can
pick it up later on
another Android device.
KEN COLTON: Absolutely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
very cool.
Well Ken, thank you so much
for this demonstration.
I feel like something
should play us out.
What's your favorite
song here?
What's your favorite artist?
KEN COLTON: Let's
just play this.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All
right, nice.
All right, Ken.
Thank you so much.
Enjoy the rest of Google I/O.
All right, that going to do it
from here at Google TV.
But stay tuned, in a TV sense,
for the rest of I/O live.